breaking now that massive fire at
silverstone golf club has been burning
for hours we have sasha loftis joining
us with an update on why it's taking so
long to put out these flames sasha
kirsten a couple reasons why this is
taking so long we're told for safety
reasons firefighters can't get inside
the building we're going to zoom in here
so you can get a better look and again
they have to fight this from the outside
defensively you can see up on the ladder
there spraying water on those flames to
make sure this doesn't spread to any
other structures you can see the flames
here again the roof collapsed a little
while ago we're told the walls could
collapse as well any minute which is why
firefighters again are standing farther
back and not getting too close to this
building while there is no official
cause for this fire yet crews tell us
this vacant building is known for
squatters and has had two previous fires
neighbor neighbors we spoke with say
it's caused a lot of issues for the
community over the last few years
there's been quite a few issues in the
past i know that there have been
squatters and homeless people that have
stayed there we've even seen some of the
local high school kids come during their
lunch hour so there's lots of in and out
movement of course no one lives there so
we don't know who they are
another thing to note here crews have
been out fighting this fire for around
six straight hours and they have to
switch out some of their trucks as they
are running low on fuel that's how
intense this fire is now as of now las
vegas fire and rescue estimates these
damages around 5 million dollars and
they say they should be out fighting
this through the night and possibly into
the morning as they work on getting this
under control getting those hot spots
out and just really tackling this fire
again this massive fire at this vacant
structure reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now